wir sollen bei ihnen einsteigen mit dem
eigenen Auto darf man nicht an den
litauischen Grenzzaun zu Belarus mit dem
Grenzschutz unterwegs sie sind worttag
die Zeiten sind angespannt
auf der Bela russischen Seite da drüben
sind Kämpfer der wagnertruppe seitdem
abgebrochenen Putschversuch gegen Putin
die Grenzschützer passen auf jedes ihrer
Worte genau auf
wir reden nicht mit den Leuten darüber
denken Sie darüber nach ja ein bisschen
aber ich weiß nicht ich will nicht zu
viel darüber nachdenken ich arbeite
wir bleiben nicht unbemerkt der Wähler
russische Grenzschutz beobachtet uns
Putins Verbündete
[Musik]
4.500 wagnerkämpfer sind im Nachbarland
laut litauisch im Grenzschutz ihr Chef
bestätigt uns nicht Meldungen das erste
Truppen abziehen
deshalb müssen wir unsere
Grenzkontrollen verstärken Kräfte
bündeln
Provokationen in Litauen einen größeren
Angriff kann er sich nicht vorstellen
Wagner habe keine Kapazität dazu
so denken viele seiner Landsleute
unterwegs in einem Grenzdorf nahe
Belarus
jonas hat die Sowjetunion erlebt und
damit die russische Besatzung Litauens
Putins marionettensystem Belarus und die
wagnerleute fürchtet er nicht
ob die zu mehrfähig werden das bezweifle
ich sehr
gut vor allem seid wir in der
Europäischen Union sind und in der NATO
gilt in Litauen als Lebensversicherung
trotzdem bleibt man wachsam Jonas
vertraut den internationalen Partnern
und sich selbst
wenn ich ihn brauche
mal sehen wir zuerst haben dann nicht
weiter nach Vilnius in die Hauptstadt
direkt nach dem russischen Einmarsch in
die Ukraine brummte dieser Waffenladen
uns interessiert wie ist es jetzt
mittlerweile haben viele Litauer einen
Waffenschein gemacht sagt Waffenhändler
Darius
jetzt sind er militärische Waffen
gefragt und die Leute kaufen mehr
Gewehre für Selbstverteidigung mit
glattem Lauf
auch halbautomatische Waffen haben wir
im Angebot mehr als noch vor eineinhalb
Jahren
nicht sonderlich wohl auch ein
Gewöhnungseffekt des Krieges
diesen Teil des großen Spiels klar da
gibt's Provokationen und wir müssen
darauf reagieren aber das sollte nicht
unser Fokus sein das ist vielleicht
genau ihre Absicht du musst Ruhe
bewahren und die Situation im Blick
haben
und sie wollen vorbereitet sein
ein simulierter Hinterhalt nahe der
Grenze zu belausus
die litauische schützenunion trainiert
wir studieren genau Infos und Videos aus
der Ukraine weil wir aus ihren Fehlern
lernen wollen
der Mangel an Erfahrung ist der
Hauptgrund für Todesopfer
ich bin mir sicher Vorbereitung
tägliches Training aller Aktionen
steigert deine Überlebenschance
freiwillige Paramilitärs bereit im Fall
der Fälle ihr Land zu verteidigen die
litauische schützenunion hat Zulauf seit
Kriegsbeginn
ich fühl mich sicher ich wüsste was zu
tun ist wäre in einer Notsituation nicht
panisch
es sind Patrioten wie Kosmetikerin der
[__] die hier trainieren
ich glaube nicht nur ich bin motiviert
durch die Tatsache dass wir nie wieder
die Dinge so haben wollen wie zurzeit
der Sowjetunion
von der Ostgrenze reisen wir ganz in den
Westen dort hat Litauen eine zweite
sensible Grenze zum russischen
Kaliningrad hoch militarisiert die
litauische Stadt kleinpeda im Hafen
kommen gerade Fischer Wirges und seine
Jungs an die russischen Fanggebiete
immer vor der Nase die litauische Marine
begegnet ihnen jetzt öfters
wir können die Anspannung sehen die
Drohnen die da fliegen
Drohnen Flugzeuge Helikopter mehr
Schiffe wir sehen da echt viel davon ich
hab vor gar nichts Angst in die Ukraine
die Russen schlagen können dann könnten
wir das auch dass die noch kommen alles
wird gut
Wirges und seine Jungs laden uns in ihre
Fischhalle ein sie sind stolz auf den
Job und ihr Litauen
Sohn Paulus würde im Ernstfall der
Heimatarmee beitreten die boomt in
Litauen eben mit nicht nur bei Waffenarm
bei seinem Vater spürt man jeder balte
trägt seine Familiengeschichte und die
Erfahrung mit Moskau im Herzen
meine Großeltern wurden nach Sibirien
verschleppt und deren Großeltern wurden
woanders hingebracht vielleicht auch
getötet
weißt du wo immer die Russen auftauchen
haben sie nichts Gutes hinterlassen
meine gesamte Familie wurde deportiert
also die Ukraine machen gerade ihren Job
für uns alle nicht nur für sich so denke
ich einfach
im Westen Russland an der Grenze im
Osten Belarus plus wagnertruppe mir
scheint Angst haben viele Menschen in
Litauen eher nicht
aber sie sind patriotisch und
entschlossen